we got this story from CNN ladies and
gentlemen they got him George Santos
charged by Justice department and
Federal Federal probe and that's it we
have no information they say it's sealed
we have no idea why they're charging him
so uh there you go spokespeople for the
Brooklyn news attorney's office declined
to comment it's a sealed indictment and
that's it this is the uh the guy who I
guess they say lied about everything to
get elected and he was actually a drag
queen or something one of the guys that
lied about everything to get elected one
of one of uh 435
that's how they're going to get the
house back just a series of un like
sealed indictments they're gonna start
indicting everybody for fraud being like
you lied to get elected and then just
stop the job description look I'm Pro
Santos man that guy lied so much and
then lied in such a spectacularly
hilarious way but how do you know how do
you know he lied okay uh well then I
would be less Pro Santos if he didn't
lie to be honest with you I guess the
deciding factor is the lies there's a
there's this picture of a drag queen in
Brazil and they're like that's him and
I'm like I I don't know that's him like
it's a Dre it's a drag queen wearing a
bunch of makeup in a costume I mean it
might be I don't know whatever makes the
story more hilarious I'm for yeah this
is the thing they do it's like yo if I
if I go online I can find a picture that
looks like Phil and then be like here's
Phil riding a giraffe in you know Africa
or whatever and people don't kind of
look like him and
and then every every all the other
stories they're like is it true you
didn't actually do this thing or that
thing and I'm like look I don't know
what he did or didn't lie about I'm just
saying like if someone says 20 years ago
if I can I was like 20 years ago I was
riding my bike and I did a a bar Spin
and then you're like that's a lie Tim
doesn't ride bikes you know how do you
know I didn't do it how do you how do
you verify these things
you know what I mean that guy is
supposed to be a Brazilian crossdresser
yeah
now they got pretty convincing ladyboys
over there that guy wouldn't cut make
the call I don't know they all claim
that he was I looked up look I got the
Snopes article to fact check it and I'm
not seeing a conclusive answer in the
Snopes article
was red George San Jose drag queen in
Brazil and they don't actually they
don't tell you
the one time we needed the most they
disappeared
where's the fact check at the bottom
look at this they're claiming this is it
like what
there's actually there's a better
picture of him I I urge to be no well
not in the Snopes article even Snopes
couldn't confirm it
YouTube video oh wait hold on let me see
New York betcha he drinks Bud Light
Maybe
speaking of uh pictures that look kind
of like me there's a kid that actually
put up a picture of someone that he
thought looked like me he's like this
isn't philabonti but it made me remember
how much I hate filibonti so you're
right there are plenty of pictures out
there where someone will remind someone
of someone else enough
or like Clint and uh Fred Durst oh yeah
so this is this is the picture
they're saying performa Eula rochards
provided CNN with this image of a person
she claims is George Santos I hope it's
real I I just don't think it's him
that does not look like the fresh maker
to me I don't know
I don't know man I want to believe they
may be but the nose the nose is
different
he's got a a round nose this one's got
you know the nose is a little wider at
the base
maybe I just don't believe it could you
imagine and look at the lips
his lips are way different it's crazy
and he denies it strongly Denon claims
that he once performed the most recent
obsession with the media claiming I'm a
drag queen and performed as a drag queen
is categorically false and they just go
with it and then people just claim it's
true this is I just think it's nuts you
can't take a picture of somebody and be
like that's him and you're like how do I
how do I know that so wait a minute is
he being indicted for being a Brazilian
cross-dresser no we don't know why he's
being indicted but people need to
understand this too I've anybody who's
ever seen a celebrity you know walking
down the street you're like is that is
that him I can't tell because when
they're doing movies or doing TV shows
the angles are all different one of the
biggest tricks in media that confuses
people is that cameras are typically
held at uh like chest height like right
below your rib cage and so this makes
everybody look really tall so when
you're watching a TV show men and women
look tall because the perspective you
have is looking up at them yeah then you
meet them in real life and you're like
this dude's very short women especially
they film women from a low angle and it
makes them look like they're tall and
then you meet them in real life and like
this lady's five foot tall so that's
what happens a lot of these these
politicians too you meet him in your
back I didn't realize so I don't know
why do you like this guy Phil what about
just because he he lied his way into
Congress that for no other reason just
because you like every politician no no
I didn't understand how that separates
him he's so blatantly lied like he told
people that he was Jewish he like
someone's like he was telling people
that he had like a grandmother that died
in the Holocaust and then he came back
and said no no I never said that I said
that I am Jewish I'm kind of and that's
all sorts of that was good all sorts of
really really really big Whoppers like
absurd Whoppers that make it all right
you're really putting it on you gotta be
a Pocahontas fan then yeah no remember
remember when that lady claimed that
Kavanaugh was was gang raping women in
college yes and they all just run the
story and they believe it and not only
well with that story not only do they
not have evidence the evidence actually
pointed in the opposite direction like
there were people who were supposed who
were at the party where this supposedly
occurred saying that like well that was
the first story line up the first story
was when she claimed that he penned her
to a bed or something and then rolled
around but like even that story that she
told I'm like so wait she was at a party
and she was upstairs with and there were
two guys and he threw her on the bed and
jumped on her and then the other guy
jumped on him and they rolled around
laughing and giggling and she was and
that's her that's her like rape story
that that was the story I guess he like
jumped on the bed and then the friend
jumped I thought I don't remember I
thought I I thought she accused him of
something pretty serious no I just
remember that the evidence of the the
eyewitness testimony of people who were
actually there at the event did not
corroborate her story the first so that
was I think that was sweat Nick or
whatever that was uh first you had uh
Christine blasey Ford and she was like I
was at a party we went upstairs he
jumped on me on the bed and held me down
then his friend jumped on him and then
knocked him over and then they rolled
around and then I left but none of the
people at that party remember him being
here there even her French like I don't
know what she's talking about that never
happened and then she lied about
everything she lied about she's like I'm
scared to travel and they're like you've
gone on vacation several times on planes
and she's like oh it's like I have to
have two doors to my house and I'm so
scared and they're like you Airbnb that
one like you're you're renting it out
it's just none of it was true well yeah
and then it was the other woman who
claimed at a party Brett Kavanaugh would
and and the boys would have uh gang
bangs where they would kidnap a woman
and lock her in a room and then line up
outside the door and take turns
Christ like these things don't happen no
these people just make things up and
then they believe it
that's modern politics for you yeah and
then the BBC is like we believe it's
true and Tim pool's wrong do you think
it's starting to happen where we don't
believe it though because yeah
absolutely because like like take the
Trump story does it really feel like
there's like momentum behind that story
like like like you were saying that you
you're not even following it you're on
this show every day like yeah it doesn't
I I feel like it's worn out like I I
like the whole wild claims thing that's
why I'm I'm saying like it's getting
really hard to care to be honest like
we're in free fall there's no Southern
border the economy is imploding and then
this this stuff I'm just kind of like
look culturally I think people have just
said shut your mouths to the Psychopaths
they just shut up don't I hear it and
then what can you really do as the
economy is crumbling
Gata cities
you know pretty much it's the Land of
Confusion there's no wild how we're
talking about some some pretty heinous
stuff and
some some of it's like I don't know if I
really care I don't know if I can follow
along with all of it I don't know how
much of it I actually believe it's
burnout man and it's every single day
it's it's several stories every single
day that you would imagine are huge but
now it's just like it's just too much I
don't know if I even care anymore right
yeah that's that's the collapse and yeah
and they they almost never pay any kind
of price for lying right I mean in the
case of Sandman you know he was able to
sue him and then they settled out uh out
of court and I think some say that
written houses launched some lawsuits
and potentially he'll get some money out
of them but for the most part they just
lie constantly and they basically never
pay any price for it deferred liability
it's like these these articles and stuff
like that if you word it in such a way
well it's actually even what Tucker was
even saying like you can say something
that could hold up a lawyer would sign
off on it but it's really misleading
it's not really pointing it in the right
direction and he could have given a
better example you know it's like if I
said a guy was arrested you know in
charge of the crime but unjustly you
might say okay that that may be true we
don't know but then if I if I if I were
to Omit that he was arrested six times
previously for the same crime now I'm
misleading you there's better examples
the example I like to give is quotes
they do this all the time oh yeah I like
when they when they attributed Sheamus's
statement to Ian see Ian yeah Jezebel
did that they literally took a statement
right from me one of my greatest hits a
based and red pilled quote about how
horrible and stupid no fault divorce is
and they gave it to Ian Crossland
here's a better way to explain how the
media lies
Sheamus will say I once heard Phil
Labonte claim that he prefers
chocolate ice cream over strawberry all
right he said filibonti said to me I
like chocolate ice cream more than I
like strawberry ice cream they would
then say Sheamus Coughlin said quote I
like because you did say those words it
is literally true and if you sued you
wouldn't win because it'd be like
Sheamus literally said those words we
quoted him even though the context was
it was someone else you were repeating
exactly I mean they're using their
language to communicate a non-truth
which is lying but you're right that in
a literal sense technically they can say
factual but not true magazines have been
doing that like what was there was this
one and I might have just heard this as
an example but it was like Michael
Jackson and Faye Dunaway get married
they did but not to each other
yeah so let's let's look for a celebrity
who just got married let me let me let
me see if I can do a quick Google search
um and then use mid-journey to put their
pictures together
oh my goodness so we just celebrity
weddings of 2023 seven hours ago who got
who got married all right so I got this
article and uh this one's gonna be fun
um see ya
got married
okay and also Lucas I don't know who
those people are so okay so Sia right
you know you know Sia right musician
singing from the show swing from the
chandelier let's just try and find um
Simone biles
well there we go Sia and Simone biles
have gotten married I like it yeah you
believe it that's Sia Sia and Simone
biles got married so mighty fine
reporting that too I try to be a white
pillar and I don't want to say that
there's no consequences to them lying
you know what I think the consequence of
them lying are the success of this show
the success that Tucker Carlson is about
to have outside of the notes yeah yeah
like the success that Tucker Carlson's
about to have outside of the system the
success of Joe Rogan and Patrick David
and Dave Smith and and all of this stuff
and I think the other cost is kind of
the conversation that we're having right
now like yeah I don't believe that rape
story yeah yeah like here we go well
Abigail Breslin and Buzz Aldrin got
married
like those are factual statements but I
never said to each other so just to
respond to what you're saying I totally
agree with that and I think the fact
that there's real competition is a
massive white pill my point about them
not facing consequences is that there's
no consequence from within their own
structure so they don't have any
incentive to tell the truth in their own
institution but you're correct that if
you look outside of the institution uh
there are very good reasons why they
should start telling the truth about
things if they want to be successful but
they're more interested in promoting
their narrative than they are and
they're completely trapped within their
dying model in their dying Paradigm
because like what was it like maybe six
months ago that CNN tried to do that um
CNN plus about a year ago now yeah
actually time flies it was I think it
was a little over a year ago right that
in CNN it it crashed and burned like
instantly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time